what's up everybody welcome to stream
Coco it's Britney [ __ ] I got my Britney
[ __ ] shirt on it's Britney [ __ ]
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us
both murasky of course and the chat
Jason Ali over there creeper in the
corner uh we're very excited today thank
you for joining us Chris Goodwin what's
up that got dark fast what got dark fast
Madeleine Sims um we're very excited
today we're gonna be playing jack box
party pack for now here's the thing
about jack box party pack for you get to
play with us this is very exciting so
grab your mobile device or a phone or
desktop situation mine's kind of broke I
got a little and when I was in Japan
first of all I have a notification this
is always exciting for me and then I got
a little crack screen there I'll grab
your mobile device and we're gonna be
playing with us you have the chance to
play and it's gonna be very fun and
here's the thing guys
don't be a dick all right I want to play
this game we all got to be friends here
let's not be overly I don't know
offensive because then we'll stop
playing it and you're gonna ruin it for
everybody no good clean fun we can be a
little naughty but you know what I'm
saying you guys know what I'm talking
about
so let's all come together and not have
the trolls ruin it for everybody
hey Christian David Dave went what's up
Haley - vos Maya how we doing use a
glass screen protector I should lost in
twitch first I should it's Britney [ __ ]
this is I pulled this this was bald this
was this morning this large on my floor
on my floor drove that's where I keep
all my clothes it's somebody smoking or
am I having a stroke
exactly cool watch thank you I think
it's from ODM you can find it online
it's pretty great my hands just been
doing this a lot okay anyway so
and everyone will Vechten we got a howdy
from well Vechten you get a howdy a
whoo-hoo and uh hey alright so uh so
you're gonna pull up the football thing
there and that's and by the way music is
great on this I love this game this is
awesome
Fabares I I'm going to believe in me and
the joy of the Internet so we got a
couple games on here finish survive the
Internet these all have great music by
the way each one has a different a
different situation different rules and
stuff monster seeking monster this is
more like toe jam and earl you know
brackets hearing yeah which we can play
I like to punch to this song we could
play this one with the most people and
we'll do this second I don't wanna do
fit first and then Civic Doodle we'll
play this at the end because everyone is
just gonna want to draw a dick that's
what always happens to be doodle and
whatever it's fun
I mean I'm fine with that I don't know
if Team Coco would be fine with it but
we're gonna do finish three first so
here's how it's gonna go so if you could
put us O'Malley on fullscreen we're
sorry
are you gonna play bathroom no do you
want to play or no oh good
all right here we go you could if you
want alright so we are going to
basically you're gonna want to go to
Jeff yeah you play on your phone you go
to on the browser you could also play on
your desktop go to jack box TV and then
enter that code right there jack box dot
TV and you guys will see the code in a
sec but I've done a thing where like I
put the code up and then I don't even
get to play in my own stupid thing do
you wanna play
oh okay good all right that's gonna
flake you I don't see what it is yet you
okay okay great
I'm in see my name comes up there's your
name man all right so now okay guys get
ready everybody got their whole device
all right and now go to the screen put
in the code
q PM q everybody that's right
and there's you can see what the delay
is by the way this is gonna be kind of
tough for people's delay oh you know
what I should put also these taut extra
timers oh you know what I might have to
say no better play the ass man or the
assman I should put any longer timers
we'll do that next time this might be
kind of hard for everybody but we're
gonna try it with the thing all right
here we go
sound off by the way hey the brother
Chuck oh hey Dan see spatula Jack Fox's
great hazards sound off in the chat if
you're in the game okay
and now I'm gonna hit everybody's in how
good is this mucus you just listen this
music for the rest of the time all right
everybody's in alright here we go
this is all about wine all right this is
all about lying this is great cookie
yeah eight of you huh yeah we also have
you you can also join join the audience
any time there we go vote on decoy
answers to trip up the player there's a
favor saying the thing you shot at
guessing the truth that's right go so
you can also join at any time here we go
I feel like oh I get to pick who all
right hmm
I'm gonna go royal property is this 1482
also again you could join by putting
going to jet box TV and going putting
the thing up in the corner ooh what am I
gonna say here also if you're stumped
you can just say live for me all right
best game ever Mohamed I agree this is
so fun it's a really good game also if
you don't want to you know Thanksgiving
is only a couple of months away if you
don't want to talk to your family this
is great oh my god oh my god
[Music]
so you want to pick what you think it is
and then the second one is I think you
can like that I'm not sure with the
second one corgis Hannah Rachel thank
you
and what did people pick I love this 30%
of the audience oh well done better bleh
well done oh this is a smart one
oh you got me fade tune damn it
alcohol feels like the winner Oh like a
2k well done oh my god
roses popcorn stop killing it what's the
real one double Cordys I obviously
renewed what that's it Oh castles that's
probably these are all good well see
everyone's lying it's gonna tell us what
the real answer is that's why you're
voting on what you think the right
answer is and then you vote the second
one is what you think everyone else is
gonna vote swans what so you get points
for getting the right answer but then
you also get points for what you think
people would vote on popcorn salt heavy
in the lead okay does everyone get it
back there here's a question for you
swans it's SWOT yeah who ever since one
program
oh geez laboratory
I mean just yeah does Bill Nighy
actually do experiments he doesn't right
he's more like a Neil deGrasse Tyson
like an expert in this field kind of all
right let's see here I'm gonna say oh
man this is a tricky one I'm going kind
of innocuous because I think it's not
it's not gonna be anything bananas you
want what I've known right you see you
see you see Bill Nye and you want it to
be crazy all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh man I don't know I don't think I got
this I don't think I got this right okay
whatever ha - I want it to be hot how do
you destroy a hot tub you pour like clam
chowder in it or something
I mean clam chowder is hard to get out
of a hot tub I think ah yes
got her oh hey really I feel like the
first one is what you wait so I do that
weird I don't know what's happening hair
is he known for his great hair and it
was also whoa hmm kind of spooky most
people thought it was lab coat
yeah garden he looks like a gardener to
me you know what if you look at Bill
Nyes hands those are gardening hands I
don't care who you are
it's definitely say hey Maria hey 1980s
retro great minds popcorn salt flux
capacitor oh yes I flew to the top Oh
what is this no idea this is
oh my god this is like a real tweet they
pull oh this is obvious lab coats
obviously
I mean but is the obvious one but I
don't think this is gonna be an obvious
question I think I'm gonna go so the
first one is not the real answer
[Music]
hey hey Alexander Pettit what's up you
poop man 525 doesn't know a Nicki
Minaj's I mean it's right you think it's
booty but I think it's gonna be Irish
babies
I love this part
human horses friend see that everybody
thinks it's ass oh but the ass man there
you go
[Music]
too obvious man you can't go obvious on
this think there's also guys there just
baiting you guys are like twins
Sam's family would be great oh that
would haters oh well done uh-oh the
audience came up with a lie that's cool
nobody nobody really went for mine
assistant well done well done it could
be like some drama some Twitter drama Oh
[Music]
Bible well done ma it's gotta be mama
right oh I guess that's kind of obvious
Irish babies no way Wow
well it's like they knew we were oh my
god we should ask her to be on the show
Nicki mash to come on the show oh I fall
into second under fate tuned yeah I know
right it sounds like dan cronin what our
writers oysters game mama there is no
correct answer oh go bed mother how
great is this aesthetic is this a great
aesthetic I don't know what Irish babies
means either Kevlar listen he needs soap
operas all right let's do it
B I bet she does love Conan ah let's see
soap opera oh man what is this what
about I want it to be Irish babies again
I don't know this is tough this is a
great aesthetic Chris Goodwin I agree oh
she has kept Larson says Nicki Minaj has
Irish babies what oh boy ooh I don't
know
this is tough ha ha ha putting little
China that's funny
big sister little China that's good
alright let's see what you guys
ah I just thought you know warts right
that looked the weirdest one you can
think of I don't know maybe your sister
isn't hygienic or something all right
big sister Greg right all right I'll go
for it I don't know I feel like you know
India is a place where every time I see
a clip of like a TV show or a movie it's
insanely cool like I need to get into
Bollywood there's an amazing Bollywood
movie it's beautiful and like the
production is crazy oh well done
audience you got that I got some of the
audience at big sister sister trucker
big sister neighbor oh that was good
that was good
that would be a good show you're Nick
she's your neighbor and she's also a big
sister no way you know it's bad when the
game you're playing is trolling you
that's just straight-up rude
Lego 2k is out of the game or something
isn't playing oh boy here we go oh this
is my favorite aesthetic the seventies
like crazy catalog fun hobbies let's get
into it that's a hell of a translation
to speak to one you're right this is
kind of fun I always loved the idea of
like a pauper Prince you know like in
Game of Thrones like the heir to the
throne is really like a blacksmith
there's something you know I mean really
it's Danny we all know that
Oh guys I got such a good lie this is
gonna be amazing
equip lash I don't know
this if you can we do quick lash on this
I'm not sure maybe we might do bracket
tearing after this because you can have
more people in it all right
DJ's good pig farmer is great bikes
messenger feels too dangerous plumber is
not how you spell plumber that's
Christopher Plummer drug mule I feel
like why maybe they met Christopher
Plummer
he's actually doubling as Christopher
Plummer we had Christopher Plummer in
this room by the way we recorded a
birthday message he did a birthday
message which I love Christopher Plummer
and it was insane that he a week I got
to stand that close to him you haven't
seen beginners one of the best movies
ever it's so great yeah so good Mike
Mills is awesome I have to see 20th
century women is next one yes
Oh bloggers maybe is too easy Mike
honcho quit flash is risky yeah I feel
you what's my FaceTime says streamer
trash I don't have face time bro I don't
have an Android sorry no face time for
this guy this is face time you get to
see my face for a certain amount of time
yeah I thought it was DJ pig farmer oh
well done audience we had a lot of
people in the audience this is great
how about plumber there's a bee in it
like a plumb bob
what like a PLU MB year commercial
pilot's dude throwing shade at Prince
Charles for no reason oh my god
yeah Prince Charles oh I'm winning dude
just by 23 points this is it Chaka
inbreeding it feels crazy with Barbie I
want to live in this world by the way I
just
love this I can't like all those people
in the boat I'm going to vote Norway
have you been in Norway neither oh
brother this is gonna be a mess it's
totally what's there big fish there
don't they eat a lot of halibut
it's totally halibut I'm telegraphing my
lie what if it's just like this is a
fake on it's just like it's totally
awesome
[Music]
oh I don't know did I get mine in in
time I did oh it's totally Danish that's
funny
oh that's so raven I gotta go with that
just because I love Raven by the way I I
saw I did a bit with I was in a bit that
Ozzy Osbourne was in he gave me a box
set of Barry Manilow
because he's like this is the only thing
that scares me is Barry Manilow and he
answered my phone and whatever all that
stuff and then I saw him like it's I
love this like our lives intersected at
that point and then we go apart and our
lives then intersect I was at a
restaurant maybe like six months ago and
I eating by myself of course and one
puts me out she's here like this scene I
was like okay and I sit down and I'm
looking at them anyway and I hear like
wash I look up and all of the Osborn's
are at a table right in front of me all
of that and then so I'm like reading my
book and all of a sudden like there's a
crash something crashes into my table
and Ozzy it stood up and and kind of
kicked his chair back a little bit and
it hit my table and he goes oh oh I'm so
sorry
I'm so sorry I said oh my it's totally
cool Ozzy like don't worry that's a
Texas you're smart about this Martin
does smart thing yeah so he's like oh
I'm sorry I think that's okay like I
wanted to see like dude we did a thing
but I a I he doesn't care and B I don't
know if you ever remember but how crazy
is that our lives separate and then
intersect back in LA I always come back
to Ozzy it's like me and Julian
Casablancas like every five years we run
into each other and hang out for a
minute and 30 seconds
with ice cream and chocolate interesting
so is it an ice cream based thing hmm
I'm gonna say yeah baby oh this can I
just like get this on Spotify like every
song in in fij is like a car chase like
in 1979 like out of like bullet or
something they are like what's that
French Connection like that gene Hackman
hello Bella Bieber I am Justin Bieber
it's so nice Bieber your who's Bieber's
who's Bieber dating these days some
blonde girl he's engaged to some blonde
girl Oh exit beef brains and hearts
[Music]
oh yes you mine isn't in here when I
said beard hey I didn't get mine in in
time
Kim chin stinky beans says m'kay one
must be Bloods is 19 m'kay 98 oh come on
you know if you come up first it's not
gonna be the right one they always go
through all of them it's the last one
oh the soundtrack is on Steve sis square
baloney
oh yes dude that's great cuz they did
such a good job with this by the way all
in the jack box
universe the music is always amazing so
well done jack box corn and spinach well
done yeah that's kind of what I want to
eat right now brains at hearts ooh
hearts and minds noodles and blood a lot
of blood
oh wow hey [ __ ] on me that's cool duck
bile and mayo why would you want to eat
bile it's poison isn't bile what like if
something is squirted in to digest
something else it's like acid or
something oh my god it is noodles and
blood damn it why are you eating noodles
and blood oh boy
Oh popcorn salt pulls it out damn it
well done popcorn salt well done you're
done beats me it's oh it's like black
pudding oh I see I get it I get it
alright well that was fun
alright so let's play well done popcorn
salt fade tune bath of course the ass
man choco Lego 2 K and better bleh uh I
think you're a liar I who came in last
place better boy oh my god Beth you're
the least like there's only three lights
the best lie oh please
best audience like mummy world's best
grandpa grandpa Joe 10 years running
winter popcorn salt all right we're
gonna play another game here we got time
for one more game yeah let's hide it
real quick I think let's go back let's
play a different
now I do like civic doodle but you have
to play on your foot it's kind of like
everyone and everyone's gonna draw we
all know what people are gonna draw
right I mean there's no point we're only
gonna have to shut these shut it down so
we got to survive the internet but
actually can you put the thing up yeah
all right guys what do you guys want to
play for our last game where you play
another game of footage three but we all
know what that is survive the Internet
is kind of like a whatever you're trying
to do like memes and stuff monster
sticky monster is kind of boring
brackets hearing has the most people
could do 16 people for this this is kind
of people choose different answers and
you vote for your favorite answer so it
kind of goes crazy and then Civic doodle
which you all know is gonna be dicks so
um
guys what do you want keep playing brah
oh you know what and as we do this I'm
gonna do how do I do I guess I have to
I'll put it on when we do the thing we
like dis games is one track bracket
earring large audience Civic doodle all
right I'm seeing a lot of bracket
earring all right with the most players
bracket earring it is and you know what
maybe I do do the friendly the family
friendly thing here what do you think
yeah we
let's do family friendly give friendly
oh my god
family friendly it doesn't seem like
that should be a thing all right first
of all family friendly boom that's right
I'm on to you guys extended timers which
you need here you need the extended
force required to it's no manual
censoring we could post game sharing
start game blah blah blah
room code hiding there we go or Oh skip
teach Wow let's not skip the tutorial
all right um
all good all right you want to slide
that make it put it on us for a sec here
we go okay
all right here we go are you gonna play
this one Beth yeah sweet all right let's
see here one sec guys get ready now grab
your mobile device slash desktop don't
grab your desktop because I don't want
you to get a hernia oh yeah
this one just you guys know is only
three things so alright ready guys ready
three two well I'd let them have it put
in the code RDI w go to jack box TV rrdi
w is what you want there's no role for
competing twice get in there the pro
machaca
if you can get in if you can get in oh
here we go here we go we got more under
guard and quit her the I want it to
spell something ham oh whoa
ah sue and gray alright everyone's got
look everyone's cool avatar look all
these cool avatar we got alright
everybody's in baby let's play some
bracket earring we got some audience
happening oh wait are you in first can
you hit yeah all right so it's gonna
explain so basically the deal is we all
pick answers then you vote
[Music]
oh yeah oh oh people are I gotta come
over there there's a big timer
what about oh my god I can't think of
anything good
[Music]
guys I'm disappointed with my answer I
panicked I panicked I'm gonna be honest
like I couldn't call it anything funny
Mon and Co T didn't even answer that's
not family friendly I didn't get that
when does it when does it wait I gotta
vote for this one
[Music]
love this one now guys there was a gross
one so we might end up stopping the
stream because people suck but we'll see
what happens
I'm interested to see what's gonna
happen with the family and friendly
situation there it is alright well I
guess we gotta stop this sorry guys
that's not family-friendly you know what
I should do it we should do is maybe a
I'm gonna do a manual how is this
family-friendly food let's do a manual
sensory situation there we go
allows the VIP that's URI to censor
people answers alright we're gonna do it
again
you guys can't behave yourself alright
you want to put a full screen right
manual sense ring yep I disconnected
people because people are dicks
so here we go now we have the power
y'all oh I see square below nieces
family friendly limits the prompts it
won't censor player answers thank you
well we want PO it's Britney [ __ ] we
want it all and then some this is not
not as wrinkly as you would think for
being balled up I can't it was this big
this morning it was this and I like
squirt and stretched it out and then it
became this little now I didn't pay $70
or $100 to see Britney no I bought this
for like $50 which the joke's on me
really at this point for it's like what
am i doing it's like the Macklemore saw
what am i doing it's 50 like 40
but it says yeah let's reveal no problem
thank you all right get in there FX ET
and if you're gonna write dumb [ __ ] now
I get to censor your ass which is gonna
be great so get in there ha ha abdullah
al r FR says i'm so cool
and your sarcasm is dripping through the
thing i'm not proud of that i'm saying
that it was a dumb decision well you
know it's Britney [ __ ] what do you want
ok everybody's in let's do it
yeah you hold your breath CJ mom jeans
we all know you hold your breath give me
a new tutorial we all know how to do it
we've seen it love this aesthetic again
jackbox party pack for great jobs Oh
best thing to read on the toilet besides
your smartphone everybody better put
team cocoa calm my moolah we're not
giving out any money so it's just
bragging rights uh yeah if you want to
be part of the audience at 69 you have
figured out go to Jenna Fox on TV type
in FX et that's right no one post stupid
stuff one one track thank you and also
now I can censor people on here I was
too trusting why did I trust the trolls
why did I trust the trolls Isabella yes
I I understand I know I'm dumb I get it
Oh opera cat got in there
yeah all right best thing to read on the
toilet books besides your smartphone I
mean Playboy's fine Sheila link where we
were only going like gross things but
was the thing Oh oh my god highlight
magazines remember those a pooping
manual guys that should be instant you
shouldn't need a manual what would a
pooping manual even say you know I guess
sit on toilet step one step two do your
business I mean you know what a poopie
manual should have is number three
should be flush yay watching Conan there
we go perfect the death of the book the
rise of TV boom watching Conan moves on
a laptop be honest in the chat has
anybody brought their laptop into the
bathroom or pooping I want honesty
grandma's well that's dark who's gonna
sit there with their laptop
that's right that's very true but then
maybe they're doing on their laptop when
they're doing on their laptop or maybe
they print out all of Reddit and just
read it I know I would if I'm going
camping I want to keep up on reddit you
know
so I've print out the reddit grandma's
will god you're like like oh what's
grandma gonna give me as you're pooping
pretty great the Bible ooh medicine
bottles of course a good manga or manga
newspaper kind of pedestrian by the way
you could switch your answers just so
you know you could you can switch your
answers oh wow the Bible and medicine
bottles or no medicine bottles looks
like it's pulling you although you keep
it your medicine how small is your
bathroom you keep it yeah here like
keeping all your medicine bottles right
there I did in college to study says SPR
Wow there we go well done I hope you got
an A for your trouble I just feel like
the laptop these would be so cold on my
legs you know ooh
the nearest magazine air freshener can
label shampoo the bottle up Conan's
Twitter again printing it out having it
print it out and if you're a true fan
like us you should have shown into
Twitter print it out at all times in
case that in case the the power goes out
you want to know exactly the conan set
at all times shampoo bottles i'm not in
the audience you can't fair enough kurt
always gonna stream you to go for
another 15 minutes there we go up we got
a freeze up Oh No sweater broke it no no
[Music]
[Applause]
that's crazy
maybe there's something with like a man
I guess it's telling us not to do this
pandering to team Coco's rampant in this
round yeah they're a it's I think they
thing got so angry at us Deb's in the
house get to see their game crash I know
that sucks but Jack box party pack for
it is awesome yeah alright well we only
have like 15 more minutes so my question
is do we play Friday the 13th
do we play another round of this oh damn
it ah
alright I'm gonna have to quit guys I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
everyone we'll just leave that Conan
hacked it restart okay fine fine oh all
right here's the thing because we only
have a few minutes should we do the
Civic doodle maybe our people look guys
we only have a few minutes brackets here
he's gonna take like a half hour
we can't play Brad you're tearing I want
to do Civic dude all but please just
don't draw dirty [ __ ] okay can we just
all agree I want to have fun you guys
want to have fun I'm imploring you don't
draw a dirty [ __ ] just please I'll give
it a shot and then we'll quit if people
draw dicks don't do it though I swear to
god don't do it I'm trusting you
Internet all right all right
I know Conan's trolling me in this game
no buggy
damn it Conan bug mister sensor option
all right yeah let's try it we can do it
all right but this one I think you have
to close your phone back I don't know if
you can get in there all right ready
extended timers for sure Oh manual
sensory it does have it okay great all
right uh okay right are you gonna go
fullscreen on us here do it all right
let's get in here ready Beth Civic
toodles guys my for this one this is my
favorite one it's the most fun on
Oh see you got it that's good all right
release the room code get in there guys
you CTO you CTO this is great it comes
up on the thing that we draw as we drive
this is so fun this is so fun
this truly feels like I know like
jetpacks and flying cars and tractor
beams of the future but this is really
the future oh we got a fork we got an
opera cat keV Larson Fabio yes man and
then the audience there we go yay is
this great there I'm gonna lose there we
go this is great all right here we go
everybody's in perfect so the idea here
is I mean it'll explain it but the
jiggler we're playing jack box party
pack 4 which is really it's coming into
play assassin's creed Odyssey please
answer I'm not sure Holly I'm getting
too much freedom to the Internet this
Grinch mode I'm trusting the internet
what time is it it's 12:15 so if you're
in the audience you also get to vote on
which one moves ahead so we each draw
something in the winner gets that's
right oh and I'm keeping you on a
short-timer to make sure you don't
overthink it okay here we go
there's gonna be a bit of a lag but we
get to see what they're drawing as
they're done
also through so guys all right here we
go guys
pressures on pressures on
oh yeah we can we can vote on which one
we like better a lot of poop on the
right side don't draw a dick I swear to
god I'll stop you don't that better not
be a dick on the left all right it's
okay okay okay I'm liking this one I'm
not sure what the thing on the left is
it's a potato being fired at a person
who's the guy on the right Mike oh man I
know me too
I'm an old man fan hey just giving me
sensor options if we do it who here
doesn't like fortnight Emily I like
fortnight I'm just bad at it yeah
audience bored Raven
hello Viper what's up hey big ones
oh you got two bullet it is a bullet
you're right I was getting nervous
though I'm about the left-hand thing to
rocket ship the game is poo poo a waste
of time well thank you for watching
jingling oh yeah look at this oh man
oh yeah audience way to go I feel like
we can do more with the old man you know
it's got more it's got more uh it's like
uh more potential my god alright I can
do with a little less commentary in this
game we kind of get it well done pyramid
I swear
okay Bork and new y'all are up next what
are they gonna do with the old man I'm
very excited
I don't know if these mean anything but
I'm just having a lot oh oh my gosh oh
we've got somebody at a restaurant and
then we've got somebody all right okay
it's exciting
all right Wow yeah we got like an actual
like artist here on the right and look
at this guy they're coming up they're
coming up hot with like a thing looks
like Jimmy lovino kind of oh this is
great guys great job so far oh boy a lot
of puking on the left there
I'm a little nervous guys oh man here we
go oh no see Beth and I are battling
don't be oh no oh no I'm not good at
this all right here we go uh-oh
let's see who's gonna be tough
oh no I have the restaurant beef on fire
I think you see but this broke perfectly
reflects Pathan I like he's just reading
the menu while everything is on fire
around its bumper - that's sitting at a
nice park at a sidewalk cafe and I'm
trapped in a burning restaurant
perfectly represents our lives
oh my god it's closed
oh it's all right
gonna lose in [ __ ] here we go what
else can we add really oh no it's got
very dark very quickly okay we got some
hair oh we got devil horns Oh
interesting they're going I like like
he's in hell interesting
guys this is becoming an existential
commentary on food the food service
industry in the US
yeah and I Rachel says it's like that
this is fine me this is fine this is fun
hey Joshua Johnson thank you so much
we think we're lame too thanks for
watching it's yeah it's Hell's Kitchen
yeah you're right we're doing like a
Gordon Ramsay situation by the way if
you guys I highly recommend Gordon
Ramsay's master class definitely worth
it he's a it's a great master buddy
it hasn't taught me any about cooking
because I'm unteachable but it's pretty
great yeah it's great my sister got it
for me for my birthday it's awesome oh
it's close
Oh Hell's Kitchen just barely wins Mokpo
nice job okay perfect
Jack good running into you too I'm not
sure oh yeah that was great yeah sorry
man have a lot of fresh perfect dinner
Applebee's the state of police said love
life there you go oh this music guys I'm
definitely going to steam and download a
like this is great perfect uh hell of a
time good job Kevin
yes that's some weird placement for the
handles I feel like it's like his mouth
is stapled shut alright guys well done
let's see who Oh
buer bork well done for a koala time
good job everybody
all right I think that's gonna do it
guys for this episode of stream Coco
thank you for joining us we had a great
time playing jackbox party pack for and
I'm proud of us yeah there was only one
one inappropriate thing this whole time
exactly exactly we really I gotta say we
really we really did it up and I'm proud
of all of us keep it clean for the kids
out there thank you all for joining us
we will see you guys for a very special
stream Coco next week we're gonna have
some esports guests stopping by and it's
gonna be fantastic I can't wait to get
schooled hard by professional eSports
players thank you all for joining us see
you guys later bye it's Britney [ __ ]